so my drinking got out of control when i
got money
and then yeah
[Laughter]
that's the clip that's the clip when you
[ __ ] advertise
this podcast that is the clip that's it
that was [ __ ] perfect that can happen
[Music]
hey welcome back to hot boxing i'm
jeremy piven and i'm mike
tyson and we are honored to have the
great bill burr here with us
tonight smoking a cuban living his dream
this is the greatest
this is the most cameras i've ever seen
on a podcast in my life
and you've got you've got cameras and
people you've got your own podcast
you're a big shot i know but i do it uh
i do it like i just have like a
little mixer and a i don't do it like
this where are you from bill i grew up
outside of uh boston
safe suburbs yeah super white
cul-de-sacs street hockey can't master
[ __ ] um
whitey bulger baby yeah no see that was
in town
all the places where they they make the
movies
i was not from there i wasn't from there
all of those
all of that stuff that they've made all
these great boston movies i i was in the
safe suburbs so yeah
okay mike was asking me your
breakthrough
and obviously everyone's got a different
take on it for me as an outsider
it's when you got up in philly and it
wasn't going well and there's kind of
i was hard a that well yeah and there
were great you know great comics that
were up before you and they weren't
doing well
and you just decided to call this
audience out in a rant that is
legendary myth that's the myth of what
happened what hap what really happened
was the first guy went up
and he got booed but it was the summer
time
and it was like a an amphitheater so it
was like seats and then like lawn seats
it was right outside of philly and the
first guy went up
and i don't know say the place hold 5000
people
there was maybe 400 sitting down and
then there was another like 200 just
milling around
and they were like okay as your first
guy and he just walked out there like
what the [ __ ]
so he got booed then it was sort of like
the tone was kind of set but everybody
was doing okay but wasn't having a
good time because you saw the first guy
get booed so it's just like oh this is
an option
so then like two three hours after that
that's when i went on and it was after a
break and
um i can't remember it was so long ago
it was hot they showed some [ __ ]
weird video of a guy had pus coming out
of his ears and some guy ate it and this
other guy puked
and then they started the [ __ ] show
back up again it was gross
and i i don't even remember i think
bobby went up and did good and then dom
got booed a little bit
and then i went on and uh you know my
first joke i [ __ ] it up and that's why
i started to get booed and then i
snapped but
all of that [ __ ] of like you know i was
like i was gonna go out there and tell
these people go [ __ ] themselves that
didn't happen i went out there i was
trying to have a good set
yeah i was trying to have a good set it
didn't happen what is it that you
believe that you believe makes you
different
oh
i don't know and i would be afraid to
analyze that because if i did then i
would think that i would be thinking
about that rather than just reacting to
whatever was
in front of me or saying what i wanted
to say i've got
information to do a conspiracy man
i am but i also am like oddly
uh it depends on the conspiracy
will you tell me one of yours okay
uh anything with has to do with bankers
that it's just like like if you started
a ponzi scheme or i started you started
ponziki we're going to jail
but those guys ponzi scheme gets to
continue on and on and on and every time
it
shits the bed and everybody loses
everything they do that [ __ ] we're just
too big to fail
um i know it's been a while since i got
into it because i kind of became that
guy that was bumming everybody out
so you don't know you want to bump into
me i'm so so how do you feel about the
bank
what do you think i don't i don't think
i'm smart enough to really understand it
i
what i don't get why like why does it
have to be gold behind our money
why does it have to have value as long
as i respect twenty dollars and you
respect twenty dollars why can't this
just be magical paper like why does it
have to be something behind it
it's all about control brother if you're
a conspiracy
junkie you know it's all about control
it's all about
getting the most you can out of them and
giving them the less they deserve
it's all about slavery it has nothing to
do with um
economics of color but it's just that's
what it is
you do you think it's all about slavery
so then you would then
they work it in racially like no you
don't think it's like an airline with
like sky miles
no how they have group one group two
group three i think that we're all
diamond medallion no we're all slaves to
something we're all slaves to something
some money some
religion i'm a slave to these [ __ ]
some cigarettes things cocaine
we're all slaves yeah we're all
initiative we're born slaves
we all have slave characteristics that
makes us slaves
it's uplifting but but but
mike used to have that because you were
taken advantage of
and you've evolved and it's a different
game for you now i agree that
you know i do agree that but that's not
that doesn't mean it's over for everyone
else no
i only succeed when i help other people
succeed right if i'm the only one to
succeed then
i'm a failure and now how long did it
take you
to figure that out like did is that
something you you felt you always knew
or did you no [ __ ] way no way
no so when did when did you like
when did that light come online around
three years ago my wife
inspired me to liberate myself from
myself
pretty much how long was that
conversation that's
that's amazing no that's amazing because
i'm trying i'm trying to let go a lot of
[ __ ] myself
um you can do it whenever you want to
that's one thing's interesting about
life you could change your mind and
change who you want to be whatever you
want
because my thing is what gets me is this
my my
my life's work is my temper and i i come
back
a rage family tree but he's figured out
how to navigate that artistically
and it's a little different than most
who are sleeping when i'm talking about
real life
like being not just up on stage like at
home
like i don't want to be flipping out
like i don't want my kids to be scared
of me the way i was scared of my dad
so my kids aren't scared of me which is
the
success so far but like
i uh
i figured out because i came from the
sit down and shut the [ __ ] up
that's how adults talk to you yeah yes
yes
yeah to be seen and not hurt yeah
so i from that bag when [ __ ] starts to
not go my way
i feel like no one's going to hear me
it's embarrassing to say this out loud
i'm feeling phenomenal they call it
namism
what is that when you feel nothing you
feel like you're not heard
yeah so that can be literally trying to
figure out the operating system on my
phone
or like my wife if i say hey man we got
to be there by two or three o'clock
and we get there at like you know 10
past three
and that there's that thing i don't know
it just i need some emotional training
yeah i know i need a lot he needs
emotional
intelligent training well i just wanted
that book that says emotional
intelligence of people just like that
and that's you know slaves to their
emotions yeah
yeah i know i used to be one of those
people well
everybody was my enemy but me
life is interesting being a conspiracy
theory
okay i got a conspiracy for you all
right go for it i think that water
in nature is the toxic waste left over
from the last people that [ __ ] this
[ __ ] up
and then we grew out of it and to us
it's
it's delicious water's delicious
and then and then i think once we're
dead and all we're all gone
i think the next people are gonna be
eating plastic
you know like like it's apples and it's
going to be delicious to them
i'm sure there's a lot of holes in that
but there seems to be a couple holes in
the
nutritional value of plastic that means
they'll live off the nuclear waste and
all of that that's okay
i know you don't believe me i don't know
your eyebrows eyebrow went up like that
do i know what are you an atheist does
that mean i don't believe in a higher
power
that's what you you're speaking as if
you don't believe in god i don't know
but know how powerful
i am confused with that right now in my
life why is that
because i don't think i i don't
understand why god doesn't take credit
for his work
like why does he make sociopaths and
then punish them
who said he punished them well going to
hell and all of that i'm catholic
what did they tell you what'd you grow
up listen i used to be a catholic
but listen i'm holding my buttons and
i'll go past the
graveyard and all that crap but um when
you really look at the
actually what do you really think about
god forget your religion what do you
think about him
how are the elements of what it is
i don't think he's mad and i don't think
you get judged for what you did
i don't think he tells you do you think
you're navigating your life now
you think he has nothing to do with you
being here you being the funny man that
you are
yeah see that's the thing because i feel
that like
if i do good things good things happen
there's definitely these laws
see my thing about religion is i think
that people came up
because they couldn't explain
how we got here so i think everybody
has these theories that turned into
religion and then
there's elements it's like if you're a
conspiracy theory you've got enough
conspiracy one of them has
got some truth in it but like i think
all religions are inherently flawed
because
they were made by people who are alive
so they don't know the biggest answer
which is what happens to you after you
die so that's like the biggest
guessing game and i needed a whole new
reprogramming so what i wanted to do
was uh i went the entire the other way
this is all [ __ ] people made it up
you die you go into the ground i went
through that and now
since then i had kids it's just
you know there's no way to describe it
unless you had a kid then i'm just like
there's got to be something there's
something beyond this this there's
something
there is something beautiful behind all
of this control
of um so what are you talking about the
wizard of oz yeah that sounds like the
wizard of oz there's something about it
something behind the curtain
yeah but don't you but religion is
inherently that too
huh there's this guy he's watching you
he's hanging out
i know religion has his flaws i'm i'm
with you 100
okay how do you think we would be
without it
you think we would be better off really
what do you think
imagine us thinking no i don't think i
don't think you you need to go all the
way the other
way where now there's no judgment and
blah blah blah [ __ ] that i'm
was at i think that uh if there was a
um no no since you're thinking so bad
just say what do you think it should be
no religion no i'm no no i don't think
that
i think there shouldn't be no catholic
religion no it's like you're looking at
an old house that needs to be redone
you don't need to tear it down you just
need to to upgrade it
what about spirituality mike there's
spirituality your connection with god
without being in any one of these
religions
i don't know spirituality but
spirituality comes from religion pretty
much
it doesn't have to you know you you know
so you alright so you're dictating your
own show then
all of my all these rules are my rules
now so i'm spirituality so i'm i'm
pretty much
i'm a prophet of some god since i'm
going through a spiritual perspective
and it's my spiritual perspective why
don't i write a few
lines in the book or something matter of
fact why don't i make up my own book
people have made up their own book i'm
sitting over here i'm the jewish guy
um i knew it you knew it he could smell
the jew
the ginger smelled the jew it's a good
choice i'm
[ __ ] with it
breaking balls i miss it yeah i mean
like looking at you
your last special from an outsider
you're crushing it
you're saying you're fearless saying
whatever
saying what you want to say and
at the end of all that and you're in
london um and you're relating to a
culture that you don't necessarily have
a great reference for
because you didn't grow up there um and
at the very end you're there with your
kid
and this is this will sound like i'm i'm
not kissing your ass i'm just being
honest
but there's some there's something about
it that really struck me at the very end
with the credits and you're
there with your kid and it's that
silhouette of you guys in the background
yeah royal albert hall yeah it was about
that it looked like someone
i don't want to say who has it all but
you've had figured some stuff out no i
did
i did i did no i definitely figured
stuff out that's why
i'm trying to figure out how to come
back
to a higher power thing trying to figure
out my temper and all of that i mean
i just there's something wrong with you
if you have a kid and it doesn't change
you
it doesn't make you look at yourself and
be like well i
got a lot to work on because um
you know there was a lot of stuff i
didn't like about myself and then when i
had a kid i was like i'm like
a kid i feel like yeah i'm contagious
you think no that's
like i don't want to no i don't want to
pass this [ __ ]
you don't think you could tell you
thought you could hide something
you know no like it now we like secrets
i have a temper man you can't hide that
like if i was you know
no no we're not hiding in timber behind
the cause of the temple
well if i could i'm trying to figure out
what is the cause of it
oh i know the cause of it brother oh
don't start that why
am i mad well i know you know why you
met why are you mad who hurt you
oh that yeah but that's what i just
figured out but for years when i would
yell at
my phone i thought i hated technology oh
these guys it has nothing to do with
your phone
i'm being totally honest no you're not
you silly dude
no you know what it is no the thing is
is you're more evolved you've worked on
yourself more
so you think i'm where you're at i'm not
so i'm learning [ __ ] from you right now
i'm not trying to be clever i'm being
totally honest like
how many times i've said that i [ __ ]
hate technology technology kept me alive
i had a ruptured appendix
i don't hate technology i just get
frustrated with [ __ ]
and i have this no this is what you hate
you hate this
it's an aggressive therapy session he
hates his
phone you don't hate technology
okay this phone it's too light out it's
the afternoon to go into my demons here
[Laughter]
over here like hey i show you special i
really enjoyed it and you're like you
know why you're angry [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and smoke a cigar mike oh my god
oh my god bill you know that mike had a
one-man show did you know that i loved
it
okay would you what'd you love what'd
you love about it
there was a couple things that that
really struck me
as performance and a sports fan
where you were talking about you were in
a fight i think it was holyfield
and you you were getting hit by this guy
and you said i was maybe this maybe this
was an interview i've watched so much of
your stuff but i think it was one man
show
no i think was an interview you were you
said you were going i was like what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] and i
thought that was so amazing that you
would think that
i would be thinking like oh my god end
this get me out of here
i don't want to be here and you're just
thinking like what the [ __ ] is going on
right
now why is he hitting me and i'm not
hitting him that you could be that
clear in the middle of that when you
have a world-class athlete in front of
you
teeing off on you trying to knock you
out that you could
be relaxed enough to think what the [ __ ]
fighting is about that's what acting and
fighting is about that's what you
it's all about relaxation the most
relaxed actor is the best actor the most
relaxed fight at that moment the best
fighter
that's true and and then the story you
told and i remember when that happened
was
somehow you ran into the dude you were
gonna fight before you fought him
and you punched him in the head and he's
somehow running after the limo or
something like that like i heard the
full story
yes oh my god like that to me was like
it made when i watched it it reminded me
of like charlie murphy had stories like
that where it was just like
you're just like this can't be real but
the details you know it's true
listen right i didn't listen
when i was fighting the screen right
this guy he was on angel's dust
and i was and i was wondering why i was
hitting this guy and he when he was
really he was like moving but he
wouldn't hit the ground i'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on
my hand is hurting like my [ __ ]
right
and um you tased him he's ripping it out
of his chest
yes i hit him boom i hit him with a shot
and he was out right right
so i get back in the car and i said all
right let's go
and next thing you know he busts the
camera it's just like jason
he got up and i'm in my car and he
breaks
i'm in the rolls-royce at the time he
breaks the [ __ ] um
the side view mirror the mirror with the
side view mirror yeah
he breaks it off and i told myself in
one minute please i go out i [ __ ]
beat the [ __ ]
boom i hit him and hit the [ __ ] cargo
after oh
[ __ ] you know when people headed because
we hear that [ __ ] like
oh [ __ ] so i got in the car i said let's
get the [ __ ] out of here
but man i when i saw the morning he was
awake and he was just really
[ __ ] up look at that picture in the
paper i was like wow he's glad he didn't
die
[ __ ] so did you guys ever talk about
that did you ever run into him again say
hey
[Music]
he'd be scared to [ __ ] with me and he
saw me i'm in there i'm hanging out
the people have like in harlem that
people have the cheers outside and in
the restaurant
he said you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you
simply tyson [ __ ] in front of
hundreds and thousands of people i said
oh
[ __ ] he's just that he had no um
he's a born again christian but back
then he had no self-respect he didn't
care
he had a jury curve remember that guy in
last dragon
come on you remember the last dragon the
movie that guy had the jericho you know
he looked just like him
i think he had the last jerry curl the
guy you fought literally curl was great
for boxing because when a guy would take
a stiff right the product would come out
of his head right
something like enhanced i know but he
can't get the punch
sometimes you can't see [ __ ] man
[ __ ] jerry curling [ __ ] so mike you
said everything
changed for you you were terrified and
you were so scared and then you realized
they were more scared of you and that
empowered you
and what bill was just talking about
when when evander was hitting you
i was that one of the first times that
you thought oh wait
maybe he's not more scared of me
there was a moment where it flipped and
that's why you're like what in god's
name is happening
i didn't know what's happened because he
was clashing me with his head
oh [ __ ] oh where are these punches
coming from and i've seen these shits
right
right and um that where the it basically
came from
got it hey what's the first car you
bought when you made it
my main the roads race all that so that
was the car that's
one of them that wasn't the first one
but how much does a side view mirror
cost on a rolls royce
i don't know because like 9 000 back
then something like that
probably so we kind of deserved the curb
on a little way maybe not the curb head
should have hit the sidewalk if there's
a little bit of grass
i don't know he did he has decimated it
just so vivid like
fights are like i don't know do you know
that's i actually learned a lot about
comedy watching a fight one time
to fight this comedy yeah i saw two guys
spill out of a bar i was walking home
from a club and i saw these two guys
spill out
and they were you know posturing but you
could tell neither one of them wanted to
fight
and all but all their friends were there
so neither one could back down so they
were both scared
and i was watching it from across the
street i was crying laughing i didn't
know anybody there and i was crying
laughing it just struck me
that like true comedy is like
if you were experiencing it it's not
funny
but if you're watching it like this [ __ ]
is hilarious like uh maybe
i'm explaining this wrong like truth is
funny like their fear
is is [ __ ] [ __ ] it's always going
another way
that one of these guys could have a
fight and kill the other guy
and he has the family and people that
love them and he has to leave them now
because of that one moment of
ridiculousness
that one tenth i know but if you saw
these two guys that was not going to
happen
they were built like me
guys who shop at the game they should
never go to the bar again
no they shouldn't it was just two ego
who weren't gonna back down and they
were just hoping the other guy was going
to walk away
and they didn't and next thing you know
they're standing outside the bar
with their gap jeans it was just funny
so did you
do you take that and run with it i mean
you're a comedian they're comedians of
dark people out here huh
you can't be stand up guys what do you
mean talk [ __ ] about people no he's here
you gotta talk with
your endureth in life most
convenient stand up guys do what what
they endured in life
oh i mean i don't know i mean compared
to what you went through yeah i had a
nice
i had a good time i feel that i made one
of my i'm gonna sit there and tell you
about the pain in my childhood after the
[ __ ] you went through i can't do that
pain is pain is relevant yeah you can't
compare
yeah what you do it makes you feel
better you know
like you just see somebody you know
i don't know staying on the side of the
highway wearing like a christmas sweater
[ __ ] begging for money i saw this guy
the other day
part of i didn't give him money because
he had on the christmas sweater i'll be
honest with you
i just thought it was odd but first of
all he was back to me he was clearly
counting money
and he turned around he had gold
earrings on this christmas sweater he
was asking for money
and i was thinking like what kind of
homeless guy has a wardrobe like
appropriate for the holidays
for him to come around and beg so i
didn't give him the money
but i mean did you look at a perspective
that you would have gave
me if you want some kind of blessing
from god just knowing that you gave in a
good perspective
i did not think that only you only think
about your feelings and yearning your
feelings control your thinking
he's doing it again
i'm not saying [ __ ] man no i
you were saying he was manipulating you
no way get out of here
i'm asking about um what kind of people
do what he does
yeah you know i don't even know what i
do anymore i just did a tour
standing next to freeways in texas i did
uh eight shows no eight nights 16 shows
i had a great time but it was like uh it
felt like i was tailgating for the week
it was like
why are you so tailgated huh why did you
feel like you were tailgating because i
was outside and it was cold
you know i was wearing like winter
clothes but you were performing outside
yeah yeah next to highways like so the
first show was always during rush hour
so you had to like yell over the traffic
so it was heavy lifting and kind of like
the early days
it was hard to get to lock in with them
yeah during the first shows the people
yeah
because you gotta you gotta hear what
their where their rhythm is then you
gotta get in with it then you can take
them on a ride
and i like it was like outside we were
there's these skyscrapers and the laughs
were kind of going
up so i i kept going you guys having a
good time and then their response was
and then i had to be like okay this is
one of these shows where i can't hear
them but i just have to know that
they're having a good time
so i sort of slowed down a little bit
and was able to get through it but i
mean but the positive side was it the
was the fact that people care enough
about comedy
or coming to my show that they would sit
next to a highway
with planes landing it was like final
approach to like love field and [ __ ]
people need to laugh now more than ever
yeah
yeah i guess so i mean that [ __ ] was
pretty funny yesterday though do you
love what you do
i do and i miss it i don't miss it you
don't do it as much because it is
yeah i mean i i still do it as much as i
can but it's like
you know one of the gigs i do it's like
it's a parking lot show so people like
sitting in cars so you kind of have to
adjust to the rhythm of that
like okay they're flicking the lights so
i guess they're enjoying this uh
that's the stuff my wife's like going to
the drive-ins and stuff
we would go see a show yeah yeah it's
weird well hopefully this vaccine's
gonna work
we'll see you know once i became my
lesbian
i realized i want i will perform
anywhere i will perform
pick [ __ ] and it only has to be one
person but somebody has to be there
that's just that's what i get i get gets
off doing that
you love it i'm ashamed that i do
why would you be ashamed i guess i i
said you shouldn't i just want to be out
there in front of people talking [ __ ]
and talking about me and letting people
look at me and all that [ __ ]
that's like that's just really
interesting stuff right
yeah but your one-man show was good yeah
i i saw chad mom and terry do it
yeah i said baby baby i think i could do
that he is
so breathtaking when he did it he has
inspired me
that's great yeah man i remember coming
to see you and you were having so much
fun he started going off script started
improvising
and he's got his wife in his ear and she
said sometimes
sometimes i'm playing with a good hand
they stop being an [ __ ] okay
and my ear
i don't think i could ever do a set if
my wife was in my ear
my wife is hilarious my wife would be
making me laugh she would be going like
oh you that joke killed him what do you
think you're special now
she was just i don't know you'd come up
with something running commentary
no yes his wife is keeping him on track
yeah my wife is a [ __ ] oh man one day i
must have did something
all good and she just left she that's
the update of myself
and then i like how you said i must have
did something you know you did something
[ __ ] you just left me up there how did
it go it was great because i was live
talking about stuff and it went great
but um i can't believe she did this and
i learned to memorize you you could have
opened
with that huh and just say usually my
wife's talking in my ear but i pissed
her off so you guys are going to get a
freestyle show
they would have gone nuts because that's
something that i learned
early on is you have to address
the situation i'm up the
yeah no any time anytime that happens if
you just address
what is going on like they love it
when it breaks the 10 then then it feels
like
special like uh like you know you did a
sitcom you know like
they didn't like when you got the line
right it's when you screwed up
then they felt like oh man i i really am
behind the scenes if you just had a show
like a taping and though everybody like
hit their mark and everybody said that
line and it all worked
they're like you know they didn't
interact i didn't get to see the
screw-ups i could have just watched this
at home
uh they want to see like the uh the
inner workings of it like cut cut cut
why are you standing there you got to be
over there and you talking about we're
going to hear about you producing some
[ __ ]
uh yeah you're talking about some
producers you produce some stuff now
yeah i got a
uh i started a podcast network that has
now turned into like
tv and hopefully a film i wrote a film
with a buddy of mine and we're looking
like we're going to sell it and uh
so all things comedy is going to produce
it and uh yeah we started
to do that i want to be a movie that
would have been your film dude
i would definitely get a part of it for
me
imagine me doing some [ __ ] can i just
tell you that you know i've been
mixing up with mike for a little bit and
he is on time and he's ready to go and
he walks in singing
and you know thank you he's ready to go
when he was agent now listen
just in your blood he's seen it i'm
still in character
can't shake it you can't help it you
can't help it leave them alone listen
you give a back end deal you don't even
have many
and you're [ __ ] negotiating for his
[ __ ] part man
hilarious listen you appreciate the
truth i have to have his back
you know what bill to be honest with you
i was i was pretty blown away that's
what it was
i couldn't believe it was happening
comes in singing earlier than any
anybody but listen i think you guys
should work something out i don't want
10
but the greatest thing about show like
say like stand-up comedy is
it's one of the like if you go to prison
it's hard to get a job but like you can
walk out of prison
and do an open mic within the first week
and people will put you on
they won't give a [ __ ] dude they'd be
like dude you should wear your [ __ ]
orange jumpsuit
you killed somebody do you should talk
about that that'd be funny like they
wouldn't give a [ __ ]
i thought you were laughing you were
[ __ ] yawning over here no the
mushrooms are [ __ ]
killing me man i knew it wasn't just
weed i was just like there's no way i'm
taking a hit off of that there's
something going on here
mushrooms baby the shrooms i'm shrooming
he's shrooming and he's wearing pants
like he went riding a horse today like
side saddle or some [ __ ]
[Music]
don't be like my wife my wife is like
dick patrol man don't be like checking
out my
[ __ ] tight pants and [ __ ] my wife's
always judging my tight [ __ ] clothes
and [ __ ] don't be like that
i told mike he should come train with me
and he said he's gonna have to wear a
jock because
he doesn't want to have to hit the pads
and have a whole situation i digress
this might be my favorite podcast
everyone
my wife just don't like my tight clothes
she said why you have to wear [ __ ]
tight clothes mike
she understands that baby this is me you
married tight clothes
absolutely so you never got into the
baggy [ __ ] when it came out in the 90s
[ __ ] no man i wanted to show my bowls
and all that [ __ ]
you know what hilarious i thought once
baggy pants came back i thought
and and longer shorts i never thought
short shorts
or tight clothes would ever come back oh
yeah
they absolutely have to mike would wear
tight shorts even when he was boxing
absolutely if you think about it
everyone else is what's going for the
jordans down to the knees
back to boxing dude that bro sexy back
the box and then i going to weigh in
with my versace
tights and [ __ ] man wear a tight
versace suit i feel i wish versace until
i die
wow now what is it about that that you
like huh does it fit your junk better
than uh
yeah it was made for me it was made for
me yeah yeah
he made it for me he made it it was
about me baby
i've dressed like this since the fifth
grade that's beautiful i have no style
whatsoever
that's beautiful and hopefully you saved
a lot of money by doing this
you use the most eloquent way anybody's
ever [ __ ] on what i'm wearing
oh god you are saving a lot of money
wait what do you do with all the money
you don't spend on clothes bill
so mike do you want it because he is a
master he really is i hate to know he is
so
he's just trying to get you in the film
i know what he's saying
he's still working it i know i'm trying
to get in the film too i'm asking him
about this
i'm not even please may i be able to be
in your film
and show my acting skills you don't have
like yeah
i never thought you would want to be i
gotta i'm already thinking of three
different things you can do with it
yeah you didn't think you were going to
get married no i didn't i
when i was growing up being married did
not look fun
nobody in my neighborhood looked happy
everybody it was just it was a it was uh
you know
i i don't it was this is like
pre-self-help
people just whatever happened you shook
it off you buried it
and you just [ __ ] you know and they
just school they just kind of funneled
you down something i think a lot of
people
that i grew up unfortunately weren't
doing what they wanted to do with their
lives
yes is what they did is what they did
and then the reality of that
hits and you got you know people back
then everybody had five
six kids you can't you can't pull the
ripcord people down
those guys some of those guys kids ran
this country
those people back then starting to had
all those kids some of those kids wound
up being leaders of this country
so i mean i wasn't [ __ ] on their
kids i was just saying that it's tough
to change
uh a job what changed your mind that you
could pull the trigger
to do what to get married
he had no power over that huh what did
do that
um i don't remember but i can tell you
this it seemed like a mountain
that i had to climb up and it was like
so many of the demons that you have
because you get them when you're a kid
they they look like mountains and then
you realize you all had to do was step
up on the curb
that's all it was and i gave her the
ring she broke down and cried i never
felt better
and i was just like i should have done
this forever ago
right and um the fear of it oh i'll tell
you
i got a chance palmitary story for you
so
it's a day i'm going to get married and
like most guys i'm freaking out like
what in the [ __ ] am i doing
what am i about to do with my life and
so
i was getting [ __ ] nervous getting
cold feet so i'm with my brother he's my
best man i go hey
let's go down the bar i just need to
have a drink before you know
i do this [ __ ] and he goes cool so we go
downstairs
and i'm at the hotel bar and i got like
a budweiser because i don't want to be
[ __ ] up
in my own wedding so i had a budweiser
and i'm sitting there
and i look i was the middle of the day
and i look over and i see chas
palm and terry standing there with like
four other people
and i immediately thought a bronx tale
now you can't leave
when they close that thing and they get
the [ __ ] kicked out of them
and then i got my head going oh my god
that's a [ __ ] sign
i need to get out of here i kind of go
by yeah
yeah why and i wasn't in new york where
he was from i was in boston
why is he here
[ __ ] i always wanted to meet that guy
why am i meeting him right now he's
trying to tell me something
and i had to get that out of my head
thank god i did because my wedding i'd
be saying this means i'm going to die
and this means i'm going to die i'm
seeing them before i go
what was when was the la what was the
last time you remember
you went somewhere where you saw either
something or you saw a person
and then you were like this is a higher
power trying to help me out it's saying
mike
no don't do this or you're not doing the
wrong thing this is just that i thought
about this person
and this person somewhere else and i'm
in this other city of this country now
this guy's right here yeah
you know yeah that's weird what the [ __ ]
is he doing here
no one can answer those questions i
think this is what i think i had that
last night when you facetimed me
yeah you see this i was sitting there i
thought i was cause i've watched so many
videos on you in interviews i forgot i
was talking to you for half a second
i'm like wait he's talking to me right
now no sometimes i think
so i don't need much ever happened to me
you think about somebody
and say my and he may pull up on you in
the car
he may call you while you think about
him he said well i was just thinking
about you
and i think that's something that we
have that we don't know enough
that we can't operate that can't tap
into
instantaneously all the time if you had
that power who would you make walk
through the door right now excuse me
if you had the power to do that like if
you if you had control of it
right this second and you and you were
like who do you want to walk through the
door right now i'm a kid
dude that's the [ __ ] nicest answer
ever all my kids are hanging i wouldn't
see this [ __ ] and [ __ ] and talk to your
guys you meant you to make jokes on them
and stuff
i would have picked lee majors
personally you were saying that your
fear is always worse than what it is
your fear is always worse than what it
is all about your fear of of getting hit
i have a question did you find the coat
first of the boots
oh yeah cool drop the [ __ ]
excuse me
i know like i said what i'm going to
start see conducting myself
and you were you're going down a
different path and i have no idea
he looks beautiful he does i mean to
have that type of color coordination on
a podcast is incredible
i mean i thought i was crushing it with
the black and gray you are and by the
way with the gray
self-deprecating but you put it together
i did put it together
this came right out of the dry cleanse
cleaners so i can show you all my
coconuts
i should have worn the jacket like you
and you got to cover up yeah
that reminds me of bonanza i love that
it was the [ __ ] pants
man look at that those pants look like
it went with that outfit
and you said you know what i like those
you guys broke it up
it's perfect mike's got some he's got a
hat going on as well
he's got you know yeah yeah you are
play player now do they send you your at
your level do they send you
like a rack of clothes and just go mike
if if you could fit this into your
schedule because if you wear these shoes
or this shirt we're going to you know
they're going to sell a bunch
well i don't know i'm there filming them
is that the clothes not cool enough i
have to ask them
this is what i want because some people
like they offer the clothes they just
i'm not gonna wear it right
isn't that weird though you can't afford
[ __ ] right
coming up you're broke and then when you
finally make it and you can pay for [ __ ]
people just want to give you stuff
then i realized that's entrepreneurship
nobody's giving me anything you know
what i mean
that's true mushrooms yeah
see another reason you see all the
angles i didn't
sit here with my soba mine what's the
best part about mushrooms mike
for you the best part the best feeling
uh
on mushrooms not being badgered with
questions since you enjoy the hive no it
just doesn't
kind of the nature of the beast here
bill [ __ ] with you know
certain elements what you mean sometimes
it just doesn't judge you
you don't have to worry about being
judged but you can get bad mushrooms you
ever get mushrooms you're just like uh
this didn't take me where i wanted to be
a hundred percent yeah
so what's the name of this strain of uh
mushrooms
no the mushrooms peanuts
peanut and the mushrooms i hear you i
was just waiting for the joke you're
serious that's what they call it
all right i owe you an apology i thought
it was a joke
hey i'm bill burr for penis envy
mushrooms it did get
heavy with these shoes when you want to
get down to your kids level or maybe
talk to god
this [ __ ] tastes like foam i like that
dirt [ __ ]
of uh vagina envy yeah that's disgusting
growing up bill's reference of mushrooms
is when we were growing up it's they
were dirty
they lasted forever and they were
intimidating they're sanitary now baby
it is kind of cool that [ __ ] is once it
becomes legal
then it gets way cleaner they fine-tune
it
yeah like weed stores what are you like
doing build up right
i mean you're not the humpty dumpty guy
the the [ __ ]
buddy that would you say humpty dumpty
because of my head no i mean i see what
you're saying yeah
once i had my i i got two and i quit
oh young i started late uh they're
driving you crazy yeah no i love them
i love them uh one's gonna be four in
the other
other seven months listen can i tell you
something brother
what my advice enjoy it
no i am and i am because that's why i
kind of love
i love the pandemic because i'm not on
the road and i don't have a lot of [ __ ]
going on
i'm enjoying the helen i had a girl
first
and then the boy which is great if you
have the girl first
because they are way more receptive to
having a sibling
listen man where a boy kind of looks at
a baby like this
they don't give a [ __ ] when they get
like 12 and 13 whoa
then they're there until now you got
another person in the house i know
i know i know girls are a trip they
take over stuff well that already
happened
yeah it already happened she's uh i'm
definitely the good cop
in the relationship but i think that
that happens with um
i think girls obviously they
the kids get away with murder with the
opposite sex so my son's gonna get away
with murder with my mom
my mom what my wife the [ __ ] was that oh
my daughter will get away with
murder with me basically
and they know how to play you too you
know well that's
i think because my wife is sitting there
going like
you know she's that's a fake cry like
she
she knows the thing so now now that's
making me look at my wife's like but
subconsciously why do you know all these
things
but subconsciously hey you're picking on
my baby
you know what i mean that's my day what
are you making a crap with not that
important yeah
no i feel that because i like when
she'll discipline her
you know we don't spank or anything like
that but it just goes like she'll just
be like hey you got to stop doing that
or whatever there is a twinge of me
going like yeah i'm the same wow yeah
don't wait
yeah i'm saying with my don't talk to
her like that
yeah she can do nothing wrong
and it's so interesting mike because we
were talking before about
the fact that you can get love from all
these strangers
and you can be celebrated and then
you're looking for it from your own kids
and it doesn't necessarily come that way
it's not that easy that's the real
deal right our kids right and that's
when they get that they want to say
they see the [ __ ] on us that our
father
people they don't see that [ __ ] as
the kids see
when we're not us
that's so true and i see that [ __ ]
so it's hard for them to
so they look at you now so it's hard for
them to to [ __ ] like be jumping on
your jack when they see these flaws
going
on yeah my daughter gave me that look at
about 18 months
yeah my heart dropped i was like oh my
god she already figured me out
that's a hell of a feeling huh it is
anything it's humbling
she was looking at me i'm saying these
people are smarter than me
yeah these
kids are smarter than me i think they're
aliens
how do you know all this stuff they also
have access to a lot more information
maybe no but they know maybe way
be the human being they're different
breeding human beings
no you think because they they can't
walk and they can't talk that they
the brain's working and they are just
processing [ __ ] they just don't have the
ability
to sit there and be like wow what you
just did was really [ __ ] up they just
sort of look at you
and you just like you just got to look
at your baby you're just like i know
i know kids i'm working on it yeah
i'm working on but the thing that i i am
uh i am happy about is that i apologize
i admit that i'm wrong
and i talk [ __ ] out um
with my kid my son's not old enough yet
so i am my best thing that i like
is my daughter is not afraid of me at
all at all which is
uh you know she respects me but she's
not afraid so
at least i got that going forward i'll
tell my kid you know your grandmother
did you you said that to me
to her that she said to me your
grandmother would beat your ass
she said well my grandmother's not here
my kid's good we're ready they said
yeah crazy yeah yeah i love this spoil
that's what you're supposed to i mean to
a certain degree especially everything
i'm talking but that's not good this is
not right that's not right
i got nieces and they bust my balls and
they just they crush me oh
it's pathetic i took him over to uh
jamie foxx at a christmas party and i
brought pearl over because i'm trying to
impress them
because i need a win i need a win from
these girls should have brought me i
would have been impressed
no she would i would have really i would
have you let's go
let's go cause she might pearl took one
look at me we're walking in
and she literally looks at me and she
goes is jamie going to be awkward the
way you are
oh god they walk in
and these these little girls are they
feel like they're what do you say to
that
yeah there's no comeback my daughter saw
venus and that just really blew her mind
she trained with venus a little bit now
you just really took it to him she is
blue she can't believe it
my daughter said to me there i go she
goes she just goes like dad can i have
this or whatever i go
i go how come you never say please and
she goes well
because i'm smart and i know a lot about
music
i don't know what the [ __ ] that means i
was just like
all right what did you ask me for
what's the name of this podcast okay
they might you might you should have
like a little mushroom in there too
neon mushroom um yes i should
i really should you're absolutely right
instead of like a four-leaf clover you
have a mushroom there
why not man i think that's cool yeah man
what about peyote did you ever do that
not peyote guy
that means did you try it no i'm a toad
guy see the toe right there let's just
smoke the toad
plus you never tried peyote
no what is it about that you would say
i'm not a peyote guy if you didn't try
it
because that seems like like for someone
like me who never tripped or anything
for someone to say here's some peyote
that's a huge leap for me and i
but i feel like if you already tried
mushrooms right
i did so much other stuff that peyote
is just small small fries to me
hey what's japan like what do you say
it's like um
assembly line an assembly line yeah
and does tokyo now whenever i see
pictures it looks like a giant times
square i don't mean that in a bad way
but it just
it looks ridiculously vivid
so what did coming from america women
don't have no
really good rights a lot of women are in
jail they're from passions and
crimes of passion killing their husbands
or something
that's a thing over there yeah yes
you've got an interesting the scariest
place i ever went what's up
singapore yeah because that was where
you know
it became that young kid yeah
and uh this is how i grew up too my
mother was just like well they should
those were the laws that's
that's what they should do um i just
remember
going through security and just
thinking like i don't have any weed i
got nothing right i don't have any weed
and i'm telling my wife you don't have
any weed nothing
and like you know you hear this [ __ ]
like if you spit gum
on the street like you go to jail
forever which isn't true
yeah but you can get in trouble but it's
not like they they
execute you or anything but um that was
a scary plus i
i watched uh a video one time of
somebody getting caned it is no
[ __ ] flesh the dude took like three
it was fine and on the fourth one he
[ __ ] collapsed sort of
and they kind of like hold he had to
take seven
yeah it's not a good thing to watch
before you go to singapore
that's not good for tourists no no
attractions
can i borrow your light and mike thank
you so much did you call your shot with
the mandalorian did they come to you did
you
are you were you in that movie
uh tv series on uh disney disney disney
oh there was a movie um well if you like
spaghetti westerns you ought to check
that [ __ ] out
because john favreau oh my god he
[ __ ]
they're killing her rick family iwa
they're just killing it over there
and um i've always i always made fun of
star wars not cause i really really
hated it it's just i saw people excited
about [ __ ] and being a comedian you just
make fun of me
yeah you just make fun of it right
you're just a miserable [ __ ] aren't you
ah
it's not as like i used to be
now i kind of do it more fun but when i
was a younger comic when i was really
angry
i wasn't miserable prick but uh so
anyway i've
been broken with the angry um comic too
at one time
you would see joe rogan stand up yeah
he's pretty tough
yeah yeah that guy uh that's one he's
one of the best comedians
i've ever seen like his energy
on stage is uh
unique there's nobody the first time i
saw him was at the kowloon in
sagas it was a chinese restaurant like
for some reason
chinese restaurants in stand-up comedy
in boston they just always had a room in
the back or a room upstairs
and this place they had a room upstairs
yeah and me and uh i think i would like
the chinese restaurants but they have
good food there huh
yeah and east coast chinese food too
which is the [ __ ] so
um i went with late great patrice o'neal
and we went and watched him and were
just [ __ ]
blown away there was nobody there was
this weird thing with boston
comedy where you had this mount rushmore
people that created it
and they didn't leave um didn't want to
leave you know and they were making
great money so
you had to leave and establish yourself
and then come back and then you could
headline so he was the guy we were
looking at
like how did he do that like how is he
still in his 20s headline in the car
loom because that it just you couldn't
you couldn't get that that gig did not
exist for our generation and he did it
so we're like all right let's go down
and check this guy out see if this guy's
as good as people say he was
he was that's when he was doing the uh
you ever see tigers [ __ ]
that was his closing bit and he sounded
just like a tiger and he acted this [ __ ]
out
i just like the
i remember the sonic like assault of
that bit in a great way was just like
there was like that bit alone was better
than what my whole generation was doing
collectively when we watched this
i was just like and that was one of
those things when you saw a guy that
good
that it couldn't not have an impression
on you that you had to be like
do you think that's your biggest
influence that was
there's comics and there's certain sets
and he's both
joe rogan at the cow loon and [ __ ]
i mean i'm talking like 94. it was
before i moved to new york
me and patrice went down and we watched
him
and we were just like not with us no
more
yeah yeah yeah i was at his one of the
one
that we wrote charlie sheen or something
that was the last roast
that he had yeah yeah that'll never not
be sad that guy
yeah if he was still alive you wouldn't
know who i was or a lot of other people
because he was
he was uh he was so good but that was
what made it great because he was so
good
you'd never had a competitive thing with
them like in order to compete with
somebody they have to be
somewhere within my sight and he was
just
over the horizon and just so when he
went on stage i
you just became you stopped being a
comedian you just became like a fan
of stand-up and that's what rogan did
when i saw him at the kowloon like i
stopped being like okay how do i get
there and
he he moved to la i just i just
forgot all of that [ __ ] and just started
enjoying the show
and um yeah i almost felt like i should
have paid him
because i was sitting there like an
audience member and people are that way
with you when they see
certain bits that you do like your
helicopter bit they look at that and go
okay you're hitting that from so many
different angles so many different
perspectives
that's right you know what's funny i
flew with the guy
that was the dude flying and he had seen
me do the bit and he never brought it up
how cool how cool is that i had to find
out afterwards
i rented this helicopter i got a pilot's
license so we're flying up to uh
crazy man flying up to uh dude i'm
telling you
once you get up there i bet you will be
so [ __ ] scared driving down the
highway
the highway becomes way scarier way
scarier it's like nobody knows what the
[ __ ] they're doing
it's like we're all flying in formation
and nobody has anything
to tell me the same thing yeah it's like
yeah when you're up there you should see
the technology you can't believe how
beautiful it is up there yeah it's
it's it's insane so
um yeah i like go up there and i find
[ __ ] i want to go do with my wife
i don't want to drive a plane yeah
no you know i end up getting into
helicopters was conspiracy theory
tell me so i was reading too much about
the federal reserve
because you are doing too much because
you can't fix it
so all you do is just meet other psychos
no
psychics and psychos you can't tell me
that you haven't met a conspiracy
theorist well you're excited cause
they're into it too
in about a minute into the conversation
it's like i gotta get away from this
[ __ ] guy
well you don't experience that you're
mike tyson you look like me
with no fights yeah i understand people
will bend your ear a little
they are in more all right so it was
mike mike i was reading up on this [ __ ]
and i've eaten up one just how the whole
federal reserve
came about the woodrow wilson [ __ ] his
letter of regret
yeah and how they passed it when
everybody had gone home and it's like
now
um they wanted to um put taxes on the
robber bearings
that's when taxes were created that's
what these federal guys these
412 families made the federal reserve
the um the tax the robber barons like
the rockefellers and the vandals and all
those kind
i thought they were the robber barons
and they took control of the money no
they're the robber barons but who's
going to who's going to put the robert
bradleys in their perspective so you
need guys like um theodore roosevelt to
do that to make these laws and now well
that's what taxes come in 1912.
but if that's what they were trying to
do then and if you told me that then i
would have never learned how to fly
because i learned how to fly from
reading that [ __ ] because i became
convinced that the dollar was going to
collapse
that 2008 [ __ ] happened and they were
just like hey go [ __ ] yourself we're too
big to fail
so never going to collapse it's just
that we're going to get our share
we want to get speak up you know make up
something that's called taxes
and we're going to tax the robber ban so
that money won't get too powerful
all right well my version of it was
no that's just exactly you read that
that's why they did it
1912 um six families
oh that devil's island [ __ ] yeah i read
all of that stuff so then no it wasn't
no double dollars it was just some
families and they said well you got to
send me the link to read that because
the one that i had had devil's island
which really made it
more vivid that these guys met in a
place called devil's island
but then it just starts seeming true
it's why the internet is really a bad it
can be a great thing
you learn a language you can do all this
great [ __ ] but if you just
you know if you're a dummy like me and
you get a [ __ ] laptop like there's no
telling what you're going to watch and
what
what you're going to believe why do you
think the government would create taxes
in 1912. since 1912 they decided not to
have no taxes
why did they decide all of a sudden we
should make taxes
i don't know man i i i don't know i
don't and i just
whatever the [ __ ] i read it made me
paranoid to live in la
and i was like i can't even get out of
this place when it works so up and out
so you got on a helicopter yes you did
uh-huh you got on a helicopter
yeah that was and that was it and then
and then i was starting to get away from
conspiracy theory and then i started
flying
helicopters and i'm sort of a closet
gearhead like i don't know how to fix
[ __ ] but i've watched everybody fix
everything
i watch this guy eric the car guy i
watch him like fix like a [ __ ] 95
honda accord and i can't stop watching
[ __ ] like like he figures out the
electrical
you know and i just i don't know i just
watched the guy and he just makes it
look so simple so i kind of got into
that
and had a really poor science background
so the physics of flying
and all of that was this whole biggest
fear
the ocean no what do you feel more than
anything that ocean
we all why did you just say no like you
know number of we all said though
i was like [ __ ] like you're in my head
you know what i'm thinking more than i
do
how of the ocean aggressive therapy
you just met me you you i you asked me
and i literally said it was the ocean
it was to go deeper no pun intended
profile
profile this is from all those years
no this is from all those years they're
having to size a guy up across the ring
exactly
like i don't understand how you don't
throw up before this you know there's a
guy just training
to [ __ ] knock your brain into the
fifth [ __ ] row and you know
while you're training that that's what
that guy's doing how do you even go to
bed
how are you not just lying there going
is he still doing more sit-ups
do i need to do a few more of these like
no but no
just did that size them up within like
before
like in 30 seconds i have to size
somebody up before we fight
you know what my favorite stare down you
had was peter mcneely absolutely
that [ __ ] thing your head wasn't
moving and he was sitting there going
like this and you just stand there going
listen i gotta tell you one thing your
eyes were just going side to side
and we all knew the fight was over
anyways one of the greatest guys in the
world
personally right you know so i mean
after biting the vander hill they sent
me to um
harvard medical center psych ward pretty
much you know so i have to go there for
a while
and um so when you sit there going like
i'm not
i'm not crazy the [ __ ] dude i'm doing
this
[ __ ] head butting me but that that that
don't mean [ __ ] man i gotta go
talk to these people with these white
jackets wait did they give you the jack
nicholson
knitted hat from one flew of the
cuckoo's nest and you're like come on
put the game on
they got like the one guy in there they
got me in there with people
[ __ ] chickens and [ __ ] yeah so um
yeah but also in my room knock knock
know what it is peter mcneil yo mike
let's go out baby this is beautiful baby
let's go i got some [ __ ] right now
i said pete i can't i gotta take this
let's go out that's amazing man i wanted
to go out with him so bad
he just looked like ah that's so cool
that you guys at one moment are trying
to kill each other
and then the second it's over like you
guys can just hang out it's just let's
kind of make some money for our families
man we don't have no
most fighters are really friends and we
respect each other
we just put on this show yeah but that
moment that he's talking about
that wasn't a show i mean you were
locked in oh yeah we're fighting
you were locked in and you couldn't wait
to get out yeah but after that
my favorite my favorite stairs
terrifying
i know he'd be doing another another guy
he's been to a bunch of rehabs
peter didn't have to go to a bunch of
rehab he's a beautiful person he just
like the party
another guy who thought he had a great
stare was uh tommy hearns
tommy heads was pretty tough wasn't he
yeah and he had that weird
thing where he was like almost six feet
tall but but he could make
weight at like 155 um
that middleweight division um like in
the 70s it was the heavyweight division
i don't know much about boxing but like
the middleweight division when it was
duran sugar ray
marvin hagler my favorite you know
because he was a brockton
massachusetts guy he's underrated oh
yeah oh man it still kills me though
i thought he won that sugar ray fight
man when he was sitting there going like
that's why i don't fight in vegas or
something blah blah blah i just was like
ah
but um but i also loved uh
sugar i loved all this guy roberto duran
i loved
that whole division and uh yeah boxing
was
all those guys were hanging with hangers
at the end of his career
no one else got there for him in this
place i do love that he
when he said after that fight [ __ ]
i'm not coming back everybody he's
coming back i was like barry sanders
yeah you could easily go out he went to
italy he was hanging out with italy some
in italy a couple of times
that's where he lives apparently hagler
yeah he came to see me fight in england
once i was fighting england came to
visit me
when you fought frank bruno or i don't
know who or the flood in england
the english champion frank bruno in
england somebody is not
fighting for him over here how often do
you run into guys you you fought
and i don't mean the famous guy just ran
into frank bruno we did some kind of
commercial or something together
periodically that much
so mike you want to do another one-man
show absolutely i die
so you got a guy who's one of the best
writers in the game [ __ ] agent here
he's putting together another package
i'm just i was trying to and if you
don't want to go into it that's fine but
i was
are you [ __ ] kidding me i'd do that
in a second oh okay
you came with me with like some stories
and [ __ ] i i've seen you one man's show
i wouldn't need to
i would just be like i would expand on
this expand on that but like his story
is
[ __ ] ridiculous producer my wife does
all my lines and [ __ ] i know but she's
direct she's the only one that could
direct me
all right i'm not going to ruin this
person
know i'm a really [ __ ] when it comes
to no but the the great thing about
bill's journey is he he could probably
unlock different ways and different
perspectives to look at your stories
don't oversell it now
don't oversell it he's good baby he's
good he said you were gonna unlock some
[ __ ] you didn't unlock anything and i
get [ __ ] yelled at
what do you do bill what's your life
like like besides the kids you have
friends you go why did
you stay in clubs i did i did before
before this bull before this [ __ ]
happened yeah my
my yes i have um yeah i have a
tight circle of friends that i would do
anything for
and they do anything for me and we've
had
some of the best times ever doing st not
even like just doing the shows it was
like the hangs afterwards
you know hanging out and talking and we
were just always uh we were drinkers
so we would just get like a tour bus and
we'd do the show
and then we would just you know we'd go
to the italian section
in in like pittsburgh get a bunch of
italian food and we'd watch like a
gangster movie
or you know if we just felt like getting
[ __ ] up we'd watch like anchorman we
did like really just
stupid clubhouse [ __ ] and i gotta tell
you i'm glad that that's the way i did
the [ __ ] road you know
that was the way to do it with all this
[ __ ] there now i know when i was a
young kid he's always boxing holy oak
massachusetts
holy oak massachusetts i don't know
where that is i just remember always
hearing that
growing up sure dick do already had a
club out there at one point
shout out to dick doherty dick thoughty
dick doherty
victoria doherty king of boston comedy
every interesting guy dude
am i or is that the mushrooms what do
you think it's got to be 50 50.
the mushrooms sleep in yet oh they did
it's got to be getting close you took
that last uh
had a cauliflower level of mushrooms
that he took what are you talking about
no just
it's just a layer because you're on a
different wavelength right now you
should do it it'd be
very stimulating the thing about
mushrooms is because it's not man-made
it takes whatever you're feeling and it
explores and heightens it
as opposed to so you've done mushrooms
yeah yeah
i like the way you said yeah i want to
hear the story yeah
yeah no i use i used you got more
relaxed when i said that yeah
yeah you felt it this is an infomercial
for mushrooms and you know what i'm
buying
i am [ __ ] buying bro we got no skin
in this game i know that's why it is
because you guys are not making any
money off of it and you're selling it
like you do so it it's um well you said
you said to him you know when he said
you're an interesting dude he meant it
because it's not like he's doing blow
and he's talking [ __ ]
and he's a slave to this man-made drug
he's it's just
it just gets into whatever truth you
have and it just kind of heightens it
dude you on blow would be the greatest
[ __ ] thing ever
[Music]
oh [ __ ] i never [ __ ] with that
you know was weird like how just certain
drugs
like the stigma like cocaine was always
dirty
it was always in the back room and
everybody had to be doing like
you know you can take mushrooms in front
of you want something it's social
it's cool cocaine was always that no
cocaine was never dirty i came in the
world with a very sociable cocaine
everybody had cocaine in the room and
everybody thought that cocaine's better
than anybody else cocaine
oh that's well by the time it came
around to me that's not the way it was
and i remember uh i don't want to get
anybody in trouble 96
baby 96 it was that was like
15 years after the big lie 96
cocaine the big lie you don't remember
that in the 80s that wasn't a cocaine
guy that's what i was oh
i'm talking about as i got successful
and i had the cocaine it was
massive and we were enjoying it yeah i
mean mike mike
and i'm i'm i'm not saying this i'm
quoting you you're one of the only guys
who can do cocaine and actually gain
weight
absolutely very rare absolutely i must
have bad cocaine
yeah oh you would get the munchies
that's not good cocaine
i don't know what it was but i got
really
large i was the fat coquette
that's rare that's like a unicorn a fat
coat everybody said man what the [ __ ]
happened to you you sure you're not
doing more than coke
[ __ ] i said [ __ ] i the only fact all
right so if i was helping you
if i was helping him with this one-man
show you got to build that out
correct oh no you got to do it in the
show
do the this thing and then do the fat
cocaine
and then no no listen
i'm seeing the show the picture i should
have pictured the fat cocaine oh well
you see that that's
that's really we've seen the pictures
mike yes
i did that in my show i showed him the
picture okay that's right i got pictures
in the show so i should have pictures of
the fat crackhead
one of the predominant feelings on
mushrooms is just straight up
joy and laughter correct i'm just um
feeling comfortable with you first okay
you know give you comfortability
yeah and what does that say about you
that he had to eat that much mushrooms
to get [ __ ] comfortable with you
there's a nervousness to you i feel it
no no i mean you can ask
it's traveling through the couch and
it's getting into me
yeah he wants to examine you know
did you have to go did you ever have to
go to um
when i got arrested for drinking and
driving yeah you
had to go to uh i had to go to aaa
meetings
and uh and i immediately realized i
wasn't an alcoholic
because you you went there and i was
just like all right i guess this is
where my life is
i guess i'm like these people and then
people started telling these [ __ ]
stories i was like
it's like all right i drink these
[ __ ] people these [ __ ] people
drink
because i was listening to their stories
i just was ever with every
low point i was just going and then you
quit and then you came here and ate
donuts and it was like no
i kept going it was every everything
ended the same way and the next day you
know
i couldn't find my teeth uh but you know
i was i was you know wearing pajama
bottoms
and you know i got there but you know
nine a.m i was standing right outside
the liquor store
standing right outside lick stars just
trying to get the [ __ ] i'm just
so then they go to me do you want to
share it's like dude i can't [ __ ]
follow this
no way okay yeah it gives you a little
perspective
yeah i just yeah well i also got busted
so young i was like 21
when i got i didn't get yeah so my
drinking got out of control when i got
money
and then yeah
that's the clip that's the clip when you
[ __ ] advertise this podcast
that is the clip that's it that was
[ __ ] perfect
that can happen back and there was so
much behind that
thick oh my god that was like another
three one-man shows
dude that's the name of your one-man
show that can happen
that can happen and then you just
[ __ ] launch into it yeah you talk
about being a fat cokehead
i'm seeing it happen right you gotta get
in on this man this is gonna happen
they'll believe no fat cocaine that that
could happen
wow this is [ __ ] tremendous is that
gonna happen how you doing
man you knew how grumpy i was driving
all the way down here
this is the greatest decision i've made
listen dude that can happen is now in my
[ __ ]
vernacular that can happen
it just covers it covers so much ground
you see me homeless with the beautiful
woman
that can happen that can happen
that could happen
mike you have a great podcast oh no but
this is a great [ __ ] park you're
cuban cigars
and that can happen i mean what the my
day is complete
yeah think about mike is he'll look at
you every once in a while and he'll just
cut right through it
yeah i've noticed that within the first
30 seconds
i'm just waiting for it i'm waiting for
it i know this is [ __ ] beautiful you
see your beautiful brother
you talking about your conspiracy
[ __ ] you think the same [ __ ] i
think
yeah how you think we got here i don't
know but if i was on mushrooms i would
think that fight actually happened elvis
presley versus muhammad ali
that's beautiful right elvis gave him
that road elvis was a beautiful person
in real life
you know he wasn't the person people
thought he was
did you ever meet elvis mike no he died
in like 77
77 august august of 77. that's right
you know that's me that's know who you
somebody how the [ __ ] i care about
[ __ ] dying 77 but we know it's
just in our heavy no he died
that was a big deal i was 11 years old i
remember that
yeah i was nine but you remember that
huh
yeah i remember they played him on the
radio my parents were dancing to like
his
music in the living room and [ __ ] that
was a big deal
a lot of caddies at that funeral huh um
everybody loved him he was a generous
dude too
bill bird comedian baby
made headlined in october 2000 and 2000
after controversial monuments
2 000 and 2 000 mike that's 20 20.
those brownsville schools man phil tell
me man but listen right
two thousand to two thousand this is
what manchester united
twenty twenty yeah maybe twenty and
twenty if anything
so he had built some backlash after the
snl monologue
speaking lily boy oh billy oh mikey i
did mushrooms dude
you did you're a beautiful person she
was funny view was funny with my shows
dude
um i i had actually so anyways that was
that's all [ __ ]
that is okay but it was incredibly
difficult to get that monologue because
you had no live real live audiences to
kind of workshop the material
you kind of thought sometimes you're not
friendly with people you know right
yeah i'm aware of that i'm more
defensive
is what it is no but i i don't like this
happy to have you man thank you for
showing up
dude if i knew it was going to be like
this i would have been i would have been
here
years ago
i feel like i'm skipping school right
now this is [ __ ] amazing
oh man this is a beautiful day yeah
absolutely remember i skipped school one
time
celtics won a championship 86 right my
parents i asked him if i could go to the
parade and they were like
no you can't you got to go to school and
i was like all right
so i just went anyway and i didn't wear
sunblock or anything so my face i look
like a [ __ ] lobster
and uh and for some dumb reason i was i
mean i was [ __ ] shit-faced
i was driving this pickup truck and i
had like [ __ ] 20 other drunk people
in the back
and i went by this after i dropped him
off i went back to the school
to get because i knew we had a test and
i didn't have the book so i went into my
high school
completely shit-faced and sunburned so
i'm walking down the hall
in the middle of the [ __ ] like i'm
supposed to be in a class
so you had to have a hall pass i'm
walking down the [ __ ] hall and of
course
the the vice principal who suspended
everybody
mr calhoun comes walking down and i am
[ __ ]
shit-faced and i was just like
just hold it together just act like you
have a pass just act like you have a
pass
and i walked by him and i said that i
said and i said what's up
instead of saying mr callum and i said
what's up and i was just like
and this goes how are you and you just
kept [ __ ] walking
because i was really thinking like this
is a automatic two-week suspension
i'm already flunking all my classes i'm
going to get zeros and everything my
dad's going to
make me even redder than i am this guy's
getting makes you uh he didn't
he didn't it's one of the few times in
my life i ever just played it cool
and it worked i think as i said what's
up it's like if you didn't have a hall
pass you wouldn't have said that but it
was the alcohol
and then that started my drink and i was
like i like i like me on
booze i say hello to people they don't
ask for credentials
the last time you worked texas excuse me
texas texas how long was that when i
i did uh i did a run of dates out there
i mentioned it
uh about an hour ago before the uh
handfuls of mushrooms time has no
meaning for mike at this no
no it doesn't exist doesn't exist are
you a sci-fi guy
no no you know i didn't do it no i'm not
really into it neither i'm not
unless it's like bla i like blade runner
was that what honest walking [ __ ]
no that was with um harrison ford yeah
oh that's the first one yeah the first
one 70s right
early 80s but the ryan gosling wants to
[ __ ] too i
haven't been checking that [ __ ] out
no way i don't think you need to man
you got penis said it's going to be
better that's going to be better than
any movie
you're going to watch is what i'm that's
what i'm gathering from this hey listen
um
i have to believe that you're correct
it's going to be some really movie [ __ ]
going on in a few minutes
i don't know what that means but okay
yeah man
it's all beautiful baby it's just
beautiful life is all love
i'm in i'm i'm in tell us about your
mother then your father where they come
from man who are you
man where you descended from where did
your parents come from
midwest all of them yeah when they move
up to boston
vietnam war really yeah
my dad was in the navy and he got
transferred he thought he was going to
vietnam but he was really good at what
he did so he worked at a head and neck
team
that worked on wounded vets from um
vietnam and he got stationed at a place
that doesn't exist anymore by his family
no no i met him but he doesn't talk much
about that
but uh yeah but that number yeah that's
how it was back then so
it was chelsea naval hospital where uh
he got
stationed so that's what brought them
from the midwest
to uh massachusetts
which was ridiculous
how it worked out for me because then i
ended up growing up
in what i think is some of the funniest
[ __ ] people
in the world in massachusetts everybody
is just
in just new england in general right
down all the way down to like new york
and everything i don't know what it is
but this just i think as we're all
jam-packed together and we didn't have
the ability
to have conversations like this so
everybody just reacted and it was just
hilarious so the vietnam war brought
my family tree to massachusetts and then
all of these guys
lenny clark tony v um all of these guys
sweeney gavin on all these guys created
this stand-up scene
and um through all of their hard work i
ended up
just being at the right place you know
what i mean it would be like
it would be like um i would say
if you wanted to be a rapper and you
were lucky enough to grow up in new york
at one point
when that was the place not i don't know
[ __ ] about hip-hop i don't know you know
it just seems like it's atlanta and
bounces around but if you were there at
the right time
um and you just sort of get absorbed
into that scene
yeah it was my life has really just been
a series of ridiculously lucky things
happening but you had to be prepared for
those that luck
those moments i was told i was told this
you know that
i mean i don't know dude i don't know
this one you know this one
the harder you work the luckier you get
there you go
that's also always told to my teacher
the harder you work the luckier you get
people did a lot of work to create the
scene before i even knew
i even wanted to do it so but yeah i i
definitely think that
i would have done that but you had to be
called to the scene though
all this is you don't think you
navigated yourself here do you
yeah you don't think no i fell into it
oh you fell into it
just yeah you sort of i sort of talked
about it you fell into it
you fell into it you you were smart
enough to create this to fall into this
i don't know what you're saying i'm
saying that like
i through dumb luck because of a [ __ ]
war that ripped this country apart
a plus side was that my family moved to
massachusetts
and when i decided to become a comedian
i got to
be in one of the greatest comedy scenes
ever the boston comedy scene
and seeing these guys kevin knox rest
his soul and all these
amazing guys excuse me and then also
what i loved about boston
was what they considered an okay set i
found in a lot of other
scenes that that was considered killing
and i remember when i when i would
when i was bouncing around doing the
road and guys would say i was killing
i was thinking like that's not killing
kevin knocks at nick's comedy stuff
that's
when that guy was on stage it sounded
like there was a jet landing
when do you feel that you're killing
when did that come
about that i actually killed it i feel
that you felt that you killed like eight
years in
yeah eight years in it took me eight
years to not have be
moving around for no reason why you
never quit
well that's that classic stand-up thing
where they say if you're really going to
be a
comedian is the thought of quitting
never enters your mind because that's
what a normal person would do if you go
on stage in front of a bunch of people
and eat your balls it's the most it's
[ __ ] humiliating well you know that's
what i think about that in
life what's that the daughter quitting
is
not even thought of yeah you know
something i don't like
about commenters on boxing videos
i hate when there's a great fighter that
for some reason
like i think a lot of times when
someone's a shit-talking great fighter
people don't like the person and they
want them to fail because
it does something to them that they're
thinking like because
secretly they want to be that confident
and they want to be that guy
so then we don't so then they wait till
the end of the [ __ ] fighter's career
you know when they when they lose and
you see him oh i love this this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he's such a piece of [ __ ] i'm you know i
could watch this fight all day and it's
just like dude you're talking about
yourself you're not talking about
this person that had the balls to get in
there and dealing with the fact that
every year you're a year older and
and so much of that is is you know with
sports
is some people live their life like
carefully through people
yeah so sometimes we shouldn't take it
personally how they feel that's how they
live their life
that's how their life is focused and
stuff you know um
we have to be grateful you have to be
grateful jeremy and myself that we can
make people
that we can cause people to feel that
way yeah i learned like
probably about 10 12 years ago i just
stopped giving a [ __ ] what people
if they came up and they didn't like me
and they would
you know they come up to you and they
just had to let you know you know that
person who just has to [ __ ] let you
know they can't just be like i didn't
enjoy that i'm not gonna see him again
no i need to go up to this guy to be
selling my [ __ ] cds and [ __ ]
the end of the show these people would
just come up to me
not by anything they just they stood in
line to tell me how much they didn't
[ __ ] enjoy me
and uh i always just
i after a while i just started seeing
the humor in it
and i would just i would either i would
agree with them i'd go i just would just
start [ __ ] with them
i do remember one time i there's a few
times i have felt bad i was i was in
ireland i did this show one time
and i was talking about that haircut
your wife gets at a certain point where
she's sick of dealing with her hair
and she gets like that she gets that
that short hair cut and i go and
the next time you're banging a doggy
style you feel like you're [ __ ] your
friend eric
so that was
that was the joke right i thought it was
a harmless joke
so at the end of the show i'm standing
there you know glad-heading and doing
what i have to do because i i
love doing stand-up in ireland i'm
trying to build the following so
doing the meet and greet and you know
i'm signing [ __ ] or whatever and i look
up and there's this woman
irish chicken she's got this short
haircut and she just looks at me she
just goes
was this the hard cut you were talking
about
and i didn't know what to say i was like
no no you always look good i hate that i
didn't say like
that exactly the [ __ ] haircut i was
talking about i just felt
bad because i could tell i hurt her
feelings cause as much as i'm a dick
i don't want people to feel that way i
want you to laugh at yourself
if i'm doing that i would like you to
look at me i'm [ __ ] got an orange
beard and a bald head i mean
you're gonna let me get under your skin
what makes you feel like you have to be
a comedian
um i just it's how i connected with
people i made people laugh
no who did you see oh you believe you
had to be a comedian
oh uh prior really mm-hmm
i remember buying my first prior album i
had no idea who he was he just looked
funny
and then i listened to blew your mind
yeah and what i loved about him my
family used to buy this
yeah so what i loved about him was his
bits were like movies and he could do
all the characters
and like all of his classic bits
i have a vivid picture of what the
person looks like like the the the crap
game
the girl with the big ass going kiss my
ass [ __ ] like i know what she
looks like how she's dressed and all of
that
and what the club looked like ain't no
goddamn hank i know what the door guy
looks like
the way he did it and i've always
loved any performer that can bring me
into
a world that i've never seen and and
sort of make me uh
see it and it was why i liked biggie uh
when patrice
got that first biggie smalls album and
i loved because i felt like i was
watching a movie when i was listening to
it
and um so i think that yeah so
getting back to it that was why prior
was sort of the guy
and then i bought the eddie murphy one
the one where he had the rose behind his
ear
and i literally bought that because i
was like well this is another black guy
that black guy was funny
he must be funny too like literally
that's what i just thought and i just
bought that one
and then i then i think i got a george
carlin that toledo window box
and i was like who's this guy and his
style was completely different from
those
guys where do you get the confidence
believe that you can do this
um i'd be honestly it was just something
i knew i could do
everything else i had tried at that
point i just i i
could be i could only be good at it and
i would always be watching other people
really just trying to do what they did
and comedy was the only thing
that i ca as much as i learned from
people i kind of knew
that in this weird way i kind of knew
already knew what i was doing in a way
i knew that there was a when you bombed
the head um
not such a successful night that you
felt rude
when i still had a day job and there
would be like eight days between
shows and up on the last one you bombed
i mean that [ __ ] set would just be
going
in a loop in my head when i was at work
and uh i remember one time
oh god i bombed so [ __ ] bad
i was hosting a show which is the worst
because if you if you're just doing a
spot you're bombing it's over but if
you're hosting you got to keep going
back up and bomb
and they already have lost faith in you
it was like oh [ __ ] this guy again right
it was just one of these shows where it
just wasn't a good show nobody really
got him
and i walked out into the park and i was
trying to run because i didn't want to
hear anybody talking about the show
and i got out to the parking lot as
quick as i could there was a couple and
they were talking about the show and i
knew i shouldn't have listened and i
just
heard the woman go is it usually like
that
and the guy's like no he's usually funny
they usually have good shows
and he goes man that red-headed kid
sucked
and i'd have another show for like a
week and i'm at work and i just had that
plane on the loop man that red hat kid
sucked
man that rededicate sucked and i was
[ __ ] up at work
and i didn't tell anybody that i was
doing stand-up because i didn't want
them i didn't let anybody i know
my closest friends i didn't tell anybody
that i was doing it
doesn't that inspire you for like two
years because i didn't want them
it was so much pressure to just do it in
front of people i didn't know i couldn't
imagine somebody i know in the [ __ ]
crowd
and one time somebody from work i
finally told him he
came out to the show of course they sat
the [ __ ] dude right in the front row
and i [ __ ] ate it and the whole
weekend i had to think about i'm going
to see that guy on monday and what's he
going to say
and when i saw him i realized his
weekend from mushroom
it's all right i'm boring his his um
his weekend was worse than mine because
he had to sit there going what in the
[ __ ]
am i going to say and he came walking
and i said hey sorry about that he
didn't look to me he goes
yeah i mean you just didn't seem like
you were into it you didn't seem like
you want to be up there
you [ __ ] walk by me and it was weird
for like three days we'd be talking
about games and [ __ ]
and you could see it in our eyes we were
both thinking about how i bumped
doesn't that inspire you to work harder
and come back and crush
to kind of end that endless loop no it
made me want to quit the job so i'd have
to keep [ __ ] looking at the guy
um no i just i knew enough at that point
that it was just like man he just came
on the wrong night because there was
enough
good [ __ ] happening to keep you coming
back yeah
so thank god yeah if this during this
whole interview you don't want to show
no
feelings you don't want to show us a
[ __ ] i feel like i
bombed out you control your feeling you
don't want to show anything huh
what do you want me to stop breaking
down crying that i bought
you yeah [ __ ]
yeah you missed the ice cold over there
i just think we're on a different
wavelength right now we're still
vibing but you say if i took those
mushrooms right now would i be
like crying possibly uh
you haven't been challenged to a fight
tell me about that i walked away
okay i i i
fought until junior high and then
everybody hit puberty and i didn't and
then that's when i got funny because
that's when like teeth started getting
knocked out people got all bloody and
[ __ ] and it was just like
my thing of the bar fights if you're the
guy that goes down to the ground
when all of that [ __ ] was going down i
was just like no i i
avoided that [ __ ] i had other people
that i hung out with that
did that [ __ ] and uh i was you know i'll
be honest with you i was envious of it
uh between black and white girls
um there is no difference until you walk
down the street
why that because the people are racist
if you walk down the street with a white
girl they don't even see you
you walk down the street with a black
girl people see you white people act
like they're cool with it
um black people a little more
uninhibited
i remember in new york they would just
be like they would literally just start
yelling at my
my girl just going like oh come on man
really she's [ __ ]
pointing at me like i wasn't even there
other than that when you're in the
[ __ ] house it's the same fights
you don't take me anywhere it's a woman
and you're a guy they're really good
yeah and and in yeah and that's i really
learned like what
the [ __ ] of racism what it is and
how beautiful my kids are
my kids are [ __ ] beautiful and
and like so i feel like i have the
answer to all of this racist [ __ ]
out there
and all you have to do is look at my
kids and then look at the royal family
who've all been [ __ ] in the same pond
of white people and how [ __ ] up they
all look
we're supposed to be all banging each
other yeah but everybody's people are
people
and we're all god's children we all need
to be looked at with compassion
all right well i think you got a little
mushroom tinge on that but
no mushrooms i mean the fact that you're
looking at the royal family going well
you know people are people
and yeah sometimes you got to oppress
another country so you get all the gold
that's what people do well we do it in a
small matter here
you think that you do the same [ __ ] as
the royal family
i don't even know what the [ __ ] they do
i just know that you seem like you know
you know what they they're telling me
that's part of my [ __ ] i act like i know
what i'm talking about
and then there's one follow-up question
and it all falls to the ground
i don't know anything about i was trying
to make a joke and then you got all
philosophical
and i didn't know what to do with it i
think life is like the even
to the um to the smallest family our
life is like um
the royal family everybody has the court
their friends
everybody has to establish power and
that friendship
that's just how the world functions
you know it's somewhat some kind of law
some kind of order i mean subconscious
order
like right now this subconscious do you
think a white woman would have made that
red-headed prince leave the royal family
excuse me do you think if that
red-headed dude got with a white girl is
he still
in the royal family he would do whatever
he believed was right whatever his
body told him love was he would have
been in a situation he is now with this
black girl
this is not the first time the black
blood has been in their family
you know these guys conquered that and
conquered the world they had they have
every bloodline in their
in their family tree you think you think
this girl right here you think she's the
first black bloodline
they've been black queens in the royal
family
in england yeah
i didn't know that you need to know that
i told you i didn't know anything about
it
i was making a joke yeah and she also
claims that
the intensity uh of the press
she hadn't anticipated that was a
variable within it all which i don't
know how you
wouldn't know going into the royal
family i'd be honest with you can i be
honest with you i don't know [ __ ] about
this okay
just [ __ ] around okay this became all
of a sudden meet the press
[ __ ] royal family mike what do you
think about
youtubers coming in and fighting i think
that's great for boxing
i think it brings um a different and
it broadens the horizons of other boxing
fans that would never be boxing fans
before
expands the reach but you have no
problem with someone who has no
background in boxing
fighting a professional listen um he's
been fighting so he has a background of
boxing
if he's been doing it for one year he's
had the background five months he has
the background of it
you know he's uh this is what he wants
to do he has what fighters have he had
determination
willpower you know what i mean and
great and that's what he wants and i
don't care who you're rich or poor
that's what you need to succeed in this
business that's the that's the seller
he's a
blonde hair blonde blond hair blue-eyed
white kid
and we're gonna kill him and that's how
he sells
he sells violence to be able to beat
some blond-haired blue-eyed
[ __ ] cross even even white
people they just want to crush him they
just look at his face
isn't that something he's so special to
have that people think that
that's [ __ ] bad news he's so special
to have that
that so many people want to kick his ass
he he could [ __ ] make a fortune out
of it
and he's smart too that's a gift you
know what's a [ __ ] gift he got he's
so lucky
have that gift it's the gift that
somebody wants to kick your ass isn't
that something to have that face
how much when you would promote a fight
like because you're selling the fight
off it's a business you want
people to watch absolutely so with you
though you had the
the like every fight was just amazing so
you had that but like when you were
hyping a fight
like how much of that is real and how
much of that it's all
real until after the fight then it's
yeah then it's all like over hey
did anybody ever say something about you
before a fight that and even though
you're sitting there as a professional
going okay this guy's selling this fight
but he crossed the line and i can't let
that go no i was always crossing the
line but
um i meant one time larry holmes put his
hand on i didn't shake his hand
you know it was that kind of guy you
know he's um
i was really dark right because i was
insecure
oh he didn't shake your hand after no i
i wouldn't shake his hand
fighters were gone and shake their hand
but like afterwards it was fine
afterwards was fine but during that
process of
uh making the fight no
no emotion no friendship no what about
the press conference with lennox lewis
what about it that was heavy i'm a heavy
dude sometimes yes
you are very intense and passionate
passionate
dude what are you thinking like you
never thought like as you're walking
down to the ring
like what the [ __ ] how do how did i end
up
doing this on the country i believe that
was
when i'm walking in the ring i believe
i'm born to do this
i'm the purpose of the difference i
believe i believe that the purpose
fighting was ever created was because of
me that's amazing
because i would be thinking like i don't
want to do this
no it's like golden state for the
biggest night um
it's coming like 60 000 or something
coming to see you
not that that is nothing is like what
you guys do
because they do that a lot with
comedians they'd be like you know before
special he trained like a fighter it's
like no he didn't
you didn't it's like these guys can get
serious but you can get seriously
[ __ ]
you can die like the worst is going to
happen to me is i'll have flop sweat dry
mouth
and someone will say that redheaded kid
sucked i mean that was the worst
that can happen to you but when you're
like walking into
like a gladiator into a ring like like
so really i miss keeping it real right
from the desire of just somebody wanting
to be
something special a comedian feeling
the equivalent of being not cold
a real comedian no i actually get what
you're saying
you you relate everything
with emotions yeah i don't know i still
you know it blows my mind when i watch
like ufc
and there'll be a guy on the ground and
the guys
the other guy's just dropping elbows
like one elbow i'm like yeah i'm tapping
this guy's just taking elbows and you'll
see the guy
look over at the clock he's like all
right 30 more seconds of this
and then i gotta go sit on that [ __ ]
stool
they're gonna take that cold thing or
whatever and then i have to continue
doing this the fact that they can
a human being is tough enough to do that
like that whenever i watch
uh those ufc's or i watch uh um
one of my favorite fights charlie murphy
like great charlie murphy told me about
this fight
that corrales castillo fight yeah it was
awesome oh how many times
corrales went down he's spitting out the
mouthpiece trying to give himself some
time
and i remember he went into the corner
and his corner man goes you better
[ __ ] get inside now i don't know what
that means
and then he went out and he [ __ ]
knocked the other guy out
uh charlie told me he said he woke up
his whole family watching that they were
all asleep
he [ __ ] screamed it was like it was
like a rockstar charlie comes from a
fighting family though
yeah charlie was no joke you know what
i'm talking about his father's street
yeah he's come from a fighting family
yeah um
yeah he was the best he's another he's
another one you know i
i went i got a pizza the other day and
the woman behind the counter had a
sweatshirt on that says [ __ ] live
forever and i was just like
i hate to tell you this because you're
young that is the truest [ __ ] thing
i've read in a long time
because i know so many great guys and
they're just gone
and [ __ ] [ __ ]
some people don't can't kill them
believe it or not some people don't
think they're [ __ ]
and that's another life that takes onto
itself
i would argue that that actually makes
that's what makes you an [ __ ]
because if somebody's an [ __ ] and
they know they're an [ __ ] eventually
the apologies coming
but when they don't not even aware that
they're an [ __ ] those are the people
that i see
that just seem to [ __ ] you know you
could him in with an 18-wheeler and
they're somehow going to crawl out of it
i had an airbag
i used to be that way as well but i
don't let people affect me
as much as i used to because now i
realize if they do they own me
you know well you did the work
oh absolutely the mental work all right
well i gotta work on that i guess
you're gonna love that part of life
that's gonna be one of me when you can
forgive yourself
that's ooh that's beautiful that's life
lifting when you can forgive yourself
yeah
surrender yeah stop beating yourself
up hey when can i do this podcast again
right you can do it forever this is a
24-hour
podcast so
should we wrap this up mike if you want
to keep your favorite i'm trying to
think of a world where might
like you know i'm going to take the kids
back east to be with the family
yeah you know what i'm going to hang and
i'm going to do a next podcast and i'm
going to take some shrooms
you would really need shrooms then if
your wife left you you really need you
no no
she just went back east in that scenario
she didn't leave him
she didn't leave me too cold right now
to be going back east huh
i don't want another um winter night i
never want to live another one a night
like new york city and i don't want to
do that no more
oh you you live out here permanently i
think it's
like it's colder than new york right now
yeah we're sherlin in vegas at night
here too
so what's that secret make y'all feel
like you feel like you're really cool
you're talking
sketching and this is okay i'm sorry
you're so good no this is the only thing
i got left now you're talking comedian
[ __ ] right now to when your next game
i'm sorry people listen
the pressure is on i'm going to the palm
beach improv and that's going to really
yeah palm beach improv i'm excited nice
i'm very excited
yeah man it was interesting you guys are
talking about [ __ ] and
i played an [ __ ] for years and one of
the best ways
to play a guy that you're talking about
is there certain guys
the way to play them is thinking that no
one
is the devil in their own story so you
can't judge one of you know this from
playing guys
you can't judge yourself more experience
in acting i'm new to acting so yeah i'm
i'm
listening to this is riveting well you
don't you can't judge your characters
you don't have the same
ideology as that character you can't
judge it you embrace it
you give them as much integrity as you
possibly can because no one is the devil
in their own story
and then who's the hardest guy you you
ever had to play like you're looking at
the script
and you're like how do i play this guy
i i recently was working on on this role
where i was going to play an israeli
dude who's a kind of a gangster
and i remember i i went to the the
dialect coach
and i said um you know i really need to
work on this
and she said well why don't you audition
by sending me
you know you doing the israeli accent so
i ended up doing it's a beautiful accent
it's it's an incredible accent and that
was
thr you know you throw yourself into it
and it's beautiful
i gotta learn how to do that because
everybody gives me [ __ ] like when they
watch
the star wars thing they'll be like i
never heard a boston accent in outer
space
and then i always want to say well what
about english don't you think it's
[ __ ] weird that you're in a galaxy
far far away and everybody's speaking
english
that wouldn't blow your mind if you went
to another planet and somebody just said
hey mike what's up
not mike what's up but yeah yes you
understand what they're talking about
yeah chewbacca's speaking bigfoot and
han solo speaking english they never
switch languages
and they totally understand each other
they had the buster balls
they felt like they had to my buddy said
the funniest thing he goes oh that's
where that that's where it lost you
that's where the reality of it so yeah
but i can't thank those guys
enough um it was john favreau's idea
he was just going no he goes i think i
really i think it's gonna work
and i was like all right okay i'll do it
i remember the first day i got there
all these people i was work were i was
working with were in like this crazy
makeup
uh like looking like aliens and [ __ ] and
i just remember thinking like
how am i gonna get into the reality of
this this is [ __ ]
nuts but they were so good
after the first take i was like oh my
god i'm getting killed in this like i
gotta
and then after that you kind of forgot
that they were wearing costumes and in
between takes
you're talking about global warming and
[ __ ] and they're [ __ ] wearing all
this space stuff and you just forgot it
um it was truly one of the great
experiences i've had
in this business getting to do something
like that and uh and then the fact that
like people watched it and really liked
it it was it was
as much as last year it was tough
it like people saying that they liked it
was it was definitely a high point so
you think you were
here um some acting what's that you want
to do some acting now
yeah like i to do uh this is the
weirdest thing i want to learn to speak
french and i want to be in a french
gangster movie then you should do it
well yeah i got to learn how to speak
french first but
if you want to you will i got the guy
for you
vincent cassell you know vincent gasel
is no
he's one of the probably in my opinion
the best actor over in france
plays a lot of gangsters brilliantly
well i started watching
whatever you want is right there you
know this guy's got the connection right
there dude you guys will get along he's
a good guy right
huh anything you want dude
you gotta see a movie he did called
irreversible it'll be breathable
yeah it's heavy heavy heavy heavy i've
been watching that show uh
call my agent it's like it's a french
yeah thing and it's but it's like
it's um you know it's just around the
office so it's really like sort of
common language so what i
have the subtitles in french and i just
keep hitting pause
trying to like figure out what they're
saying i mean the comedy doesn't work
because it goes by too quick but
my wife hates that i love um to read
yeah there's people who won't do that
like i just want to watch a movie i
don't want to sit here reading
my thing is i i'm really bad at reading
so i
it always goes by that's how i learned
how to be about reading subtitles and
stuff
i get anxiety like when i would go to
the movies and there was like subtitles
like it would take me back to being in
high school and just flunking everything
and the [ __ ] would always go by too
quick and i'd have to ask my wife
what did they say she'd be hitting me
going shut up because my wife can read
really fast
but it's cool seeing people in other
cultures like that and and being able to
immerse yourself in that
yeah i've been watching the criterion
channel it's [ __ ] amazing
it's [ __ ] amazing i think what's
going to happen is we're going to
continue talking and we're going to look
up and everyone's going to be gone
you ever get that feeling an audience
already
some people have already went home man
all right well this has been cool man
this has been amazing right
two cuban cigars hell [ __ ] yeah man
i have a whole new perspective on
mushrooms like
i mean in a good way i'm not being an
[ __ ] i'm like yeah
oh all right but you are truly welcome
back any time isn't that right
when does this come out so my wife
doesn't think i just went to us
we're not filming anything this has not
been documented
you mean to a [ __ ] podcast you
wouldn't hung out with your friends this
isn't a podcast
bro this is nothing we're just hanging
out these are these aren't even on okay
i said no to mushrooms 15 times
all right i was working documented i was
working
it's got a are character to get
i got to tell you it's it it's an honor
to meet you thank you so much
for all the stuff that i've watched for
decades the stuff that you've done
i still watch all of your stuff follow
you on instagram and all that you
you're and watching you evolve and all
that has been
amazing jeremy you're all right matt
thank you brother
you see that i'm [ __ ] with you yes i
love you i love you man
i love you thanks for having me
[Music]
you